[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is Lisa and I'll be
your host today so without further Ado
let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about the
top 10 movies with the biggest influence
on the film
industry as we know the film industry
has been shaped and influenced by
numerous movies over the years but some
have left an indelible Mark that
continues to resonate to this day here
in no particular order are 10 movies
that have had a significant impact on
the film industry number one Citizen
Cane
1941 directed by Orson Wellies this
groundbreaking film is often considered
one of the greatest of all time its
innovative storytelling techniques
including flashbacks and deep focused
cinematography have inspired generations
of
filmmakers the plot of Citizen Cane
centers on the rise and fall of
publishing magnate Charles Foster Kane
following kan's death at the start of
the film a reporter interviews those who
knew Cain in an attempt to better
understand his life and the meaning of
rose bud his last word word c has a
plutocrats obsession with trying to
control those around him in the way that
he controls his media Empire whose
purpose in turn is to control the way
people think and this is the final
unspoken moral of Citizen Cain a
terrible tragedy of ownership and
egotism a narcissistic
drowning number two Star Wars
1977 George Lucas's Space Opera
revolutionized the way movies are made
and marketed its groundbreaking visual
effects and epic storytelling captivated
audiences worldwide and the franchise's
enduring success pav the way for the
modern Blockbuster the movie is about
how the Imperial forces under orders
from the cruel Darth Vader hold Princess
Leah hostage in their efforts to quell
the Rebellion against the Galactic
Empire Luke Skywalker and H solo captain
of the Millennium Falcon worked together
to rescue the beautiful princess help
the Rebel Alliance and restore freedom
and Justice to the Galaxy number three
The Godfather
1972 Francis fortus Masterpiece
redefined the gangster genre its complex
characters meticulous attention to
detail and Powerful performances set a
new standard for storytelling inspiring
countless of filmmakers to explore
themes of power family and
loyalty this mob drama based on Mario
puzo's novel of the same name focuses on
the powerful Italian American Crime
family of Don VTO
corleon when the Don's youngest son
Michael alpacino reluctantly joins the
mafia he becomes involved in the
inevitable cycle of violence and
betrayal although Michael tries to
maintain a normal relationship with his
wife Kay he's drawn deeper into the
family
business number four Jaws 1975 Stevens
B's Thriller about a man eating shark
became the first true summer blood
Buster its success forever changed the
way movies are released and marketed
leading to the rise of the high concept
big budget Blockbuster era when a young
woman is killed by a shark near the New
England tourist town of AMD Island
police chief Martin Brody wants to close
the beaches but mayor Larry Von
overrules him fearing that the loss of
tourist Revenue will the town it
theologist Matt Hooper and Grizzle Ship
Captain Quint offered to help bro
capture the killer Beast and the trio
engaged in an epic battle of man versus
nature number five Pulp Fiction
1994 Quenton Tarantino's nonlinear
narrative and stylized dialogue made a
significant impact on independent film
making its unconventional structure and
pop culture references inspired a new
wave of filmmakers to push boundaries
and experiment with storytelling
techniques it tells four intertwining
Tales of crime and violence in Los
Angeles California the title refers to
the pulp magazines and hardboiled crime
novels popular during the mid 20th
century known for their graphic violence
and Punchy
dialogue number six The Matrix 1999 the
wowski siblings Sci-Fi Action film
introduced revolutionary visual effects
known as Bulet time and popularize the
concept of virtual reality its
innovative approach to storytelling and
groundbreaking action sequences influen
numerous films in the years that
followed Neo the main character believes
in Morpheus an elusive figure considered
to be the most dangerous man man alive
can answer his question what is the
Matrix Neo is contacted by Trinity a
beautiful stranger who leads him into an
underworld where he meets Morpheus they
fight a brutal Battle of their lives
against a number of viciously
intelligent secret agents it is a truth
that could cause Neo something more
precious than his life number seven the
Lord of the Rings triology 2001 till
2003 directed by Peter Jackson This Epic
Fantasy series brought JRR token's
Middle Earth to life in stunning detail
its seamless integration of CGI
practical effects and Grand scale set a
new new Benchmark for Fantasy film
making and expanded the possibilities of
the genre the plot of The Lord of the
Rings is about the war of the peoples of
the fantasy world Middle Earth against a
dark lord known as
Sauron at the same time they tried to
destroy a ring which would give Sauron a
lot of power if he got it but the only
place to destroy the ring is deep into
sar's land
mortar number eight the Shashank
Redemption
1994 although not a commercial success
upon his release Frank deron's prison
drama gained a cult following and became
one of the most beloved films of all
time its powerful storytelling and
themes of Hope and Redemption have
inspired filmmakers and audiences alike
Andy def freny is sentenced to two
consecutive life terms in prison for the
murders of his wife and her lover and is
sentenced to a tough prison however only
Andy knows he didn't commit the crimes
while there he forms a friendship with
red experiences brutality of prison life
adapts helps the warden Etc all in 19
years number nine black panther 2018
Ryan cougler superhero film shattered
box office records and became a cultural
phenomenon it showcased the power of
diverse storytelling challenging
industry norms and Paving the way for
more inclusive representation in
mainstream Cinema as after the death of
his father tala returns home to the
African nation of ukanda to take his
rightful place as king when a powerful
enemy suddenly reappears to tala's metal
as king and as black panther gu tested
when he's drawn into a conflict that
puts the fate of wakanda and the entire
world at risk faced with danger the
young king must rally his allies and
release the full power of black panther
to defeat his foes and secure the safety
of his people number 10 Avatar 2009
James camerson visually stunning sci-fi
epic revolutionized the use of 3D
technology and pushed the boundaries of
visual effects its immense success
demonstrated the potential of immersive
cinematic experiences and set new
benchmarks for box office earnings on
the Lush alien world of Pandora live the
na'vi beings who appear primitive but
are highly evolved because of the
planet's environment is poisonous human
na'vi hybrids called avatars must link
to human Minds to allow for free
movement on Pandora Jake Sully a
paralyzed former Marine becomes mobile
again through one such Avatar and falls
in love with na'vi woman as a bond with
her grows he is drawn into a battle for
the survival of her world these 10
movies represent a diverse range of
genres and eras but they all share one
common trait their profound influence on
the film industry through their
Innovations storytelling and Technical
achievements they have shaped the way
movies are made marketed and enjoyed by
audiences around the world thank you so
much for joining us on this episode of
high school memories it's been an
incredible journey and we're so glad you
came along for the ride until next time
take care